Bop, bop! Prr...
Keep going.
Wait.
No.
Billie passed her test.
She can drive now.
Ooh!
I can be alone, though.
That's what's important.
This is my parents' bed,
and I sleep in here
because I'm scared
of monsters in my room.
-Billie.
-Ohh!
I love you.
Why can't we just miss people, though?
Why do we have to cope?
Why can't we just let it happen?
Because it hurts.
I can't believe my dream car
is in my driveway.
We're getting a car with
all the safety bells and whistles.
Something y--
Are you guys okay?
Hey, you guys need to be okay.
'Cause ya'll are the reason I'm okay. Okay?
I love you.
I just want us all to be
in the moment for this song,
because I feel like...
in life we tend to do things and then...
we're always looking forward
to the next thing.
We're never thinking about
what's happening right now.
And this is happening right now.
We are never gonna be
in this moment ever again.
So why don't we be in the moment yeah?
One more.
There's two more shows.
This is one.
♪ I'm the bad guy ♪
♪ I'm-I'm a bad guy ♪
♪ Bad guy ♪